les grues travaillent sans relâche
halifax la construction résidentielle va
bon train le marché immobilier est en
surchauffe et la plupart des
transactions immobilières se termine en
surenchère depuis le début de la
pandémie les prix des maisons ont bondi
de 30% en moyenne en nouvelle écosse
c'est le conte est rendu à van la parra
demi ici dans les mémés maison de 400
avec ses falaises rocheuses et la
province séduit je dirais le trois quart
des personnes ici non htc des gens de
l'extérieur de la province pour accor
ontario et puis alberto et puis
vancouver
nathalie langlois a fait le grand saut
il y à un mois sur monoparentales puis
je trouvais aussi partir c'est de
toronto pour un avantage
l'enseignante aux primaires ne pouvait
se douter que l'achat d'une maison
s'annonçait périlleux et dispendieux
dans les maritimes finalement s'il n'y a
pas assez
d'inventaire puis a passé une maison
dans mon budget à moi alors cédé grosse
surprise c'est décevant en même temps
avoir
après un mois de recherche elle a
finalement trouvé une maison en location
pour une durée de quatre mois seulement
ma maison que je loue c'est la même
chose c'est le même montant qu'à toronto
alors ça c'est près de 2000 $ ça c'est
quand on est vraiment dans une crise
un constat d'échec pour le professeur
jeff carr abano les difficultés qui
prouvent les membres de la classe
moyenne accéder à la propriété témoigne
selon lui du désengagement du
gouvernement fédéral en matière de
logement dans les années 90 mais non on
en voit les conséquences de trente
années ferrières avec d'hébergement
et cette crise exacerbe les tensions
sociales le démantèlement musclé de
campements centre ville d'halifax au
mois d'août a suscité une vive
opposition
les manifestations pour dénoncer le
manque de logements abordables se
multiplient on l'a vu une réelle de
groupements ont besoin adn mais pas
comme ça
si jeff carr abano voit d'un bon oeil
les promesses qui fusent de toutes parts
durant la campagne électorale il croit
que le gouvernement doit investir dans
des logements abordables tout en faisant
une mise en garde contre les politiques
inflationnistes le marché privé ça
marche pas on a les maisons mais non qui
vont pour millions de dollars à halifax
il s'était jamais comme ça que ce soit
les promesses d'investissements massifs
en logements sociaux les positions de
taxes aux investisseurs étrangers ou la
conversion de bureau abandonné en
logements ce que nathalie langlois
souhaite avant tout c'est que les élus
tiennent leurs promesses quand tu vois
d'une province en ont vraiment n'y a pas
de changement et ça devient un
enfant selon une analyse de la banque
scotia pour rattraper la moyenne de
logements par habitant des pays du g7 le
canada a besoin de 1 million 800 mille
nous logement le npd en promet 500
milles les conservateurs un million et
les libéraux 1 million 400 mille
[Musique]